I'm driving to this person's house to go
deliberate so I look it up online it's
Kylie Jenner's house it's literally a 12
order for [ __ ] pepperoni yeah Kylie
Jenner might not be giving this delivery
person five stars and she's speaking out
against claims related to her newborn
son baby number two congratulations
thank you here's how it went down I
literally last minute leave my house to
go do an order and as I'm driving by I
see all the security and stuff I'm like
wait this house looks so familiar
Instagram driver Pablo Tamayo takes a
tick tock with claims he delivered
groceries to the beauty Mobile's home
now look wait there's no way this can be
Kylie Jenner so I was like I need to
look it up so I look it up online it's
Kylie Jenner's house Kylie Jenner's Los
Angeles house in the homey Hills it's
literally a 12 order for [ __ ]
pepperoni this didn't pay me more but
they said I can't leave it out that I
have to call and have to go through the
gate I'm so nervous I'm shaking I swear
I'm gonna see stormy outside she's gonna
be like who are you you look poor I
don't know I'm nervous next he shares
video allegedly of himself approaching
Kylie's residence
you guys I am freaking out right now oh
my gosh I don't know how I'm supposed to
get in I have an order for Ashton
Kylie Jenner's house all these Hollywood
tour buses keep stopping I went in there
and they're in there not a big deal they
should be asking for pictures of me
because I just went to Kylie's house
Pablo gives a Beat by beat rundown of
the transaction and among his claims is
that he got a peek inside Kylie's home
you guys I'm shaking right now I just
handed it to the guy who's the guy is
this for instacart and I was a guy he's
a cool I was like is this Kylie Jenner's
house he's like yeah as all these
Hollywood buses are coming by he's like
oh come with me just to bring it in
there I literally walk with him the gate
is closing behind me I'm walking through
this little pathway with like a river
beneath it and then I just leave it at
the front door I get to look into the
whole house I see all these assistants
all these maids and [ __ ] I didn't see
Kylie I didn't see stormy but I swear I
heard a baby scream but the story
doesn't end there Kylie apparently
didn't mince words in the post comment
section and now deleted messages Kylie
wrote quote no one comes through the
gate and that Pablo lied about seeing
through her windows and hearing her son
cry Kylie also explained quote the lying
for attention rubs me the wrong way
finally Kylie chose a tongue-in-cheek
way to cap off the matter showing her
yourself making a sandwich seemingly
with Pablo's delivery
[Music]
at the end she takes a bite of the
sandwich as Travis Scott watches on
Kylie captioned the video quote I'm
convinced you either love mayo or
absolutely hate it I love it she even
added quote if you don't know what I'm
talking about just carry on
baby number two congratulations thank
you the matter follows Kylie and Travis
welcoming their son in February the
parents have been private when it comes
to their family life and have yet to
share a full photo of their baby boy
after announcing in March his name will
no longer be wolf which Kylie recently
opened up to ET about but not a wolf why
not wolf
and what is the name wolf was never on
our list okay
um it just was actually something Chloe
suggested and I liked it but I liked the
name I don't think anything
I love it I love it I like wolf I just
wasn't him
[Music]